could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
if i knew now what i knew then i would
have done a different
journey
dance album dj of the year
diplo diplo and i just remember
i did this whole circuit working all
these young rappers they were like
really young they were like 19 20. and
these rappers all started to die you
know little peep overdosed ex was was
shot nobody really cares about like all
the adoration you get you care about the
people that don't like you and that you
get caught up in that
it's not a consistent paycheck music
never is and it wasn't for me for three
four years one month i'm not doing good
i don't care i can't pay rent i'm
homeless what's the the sacrifice or the
cost in terms of like personal life
balance i have to answer that
[Music]
wes
yeah um
whenever i do this podcast up i always
get really intrigued by the the
formative years of someone's life
and in your story
um
it seemed like a very very humble
beginning when i look at
where you started under the age of 14
um i couldn't quite piece together
myself obviously
how that early upbringing had led you to
becoming who you are today
is there is there anything when from
below the age of say like 14 that you
can point at and say if that hadn't
happened
or if that if i hadn't had that
experience or that interaction with a
family member or grandfather whatever it
might be i i don't think i would be here
today
i didn't start really
producing releasing music till like my
mid-20s because it was pretty late i was
doing things but not actually at a level
where i quit my job and it's my main
source of income
but when i was younger um i was a pretty
bad kid i was bouncing from high schools
in different middle schools and
i was i was actually sent to a military
school at one point at like that age
like 14.
um and i even got expelled from there
and then like that was like the last my
my last shot right and i came back
they let me back in because it cost my
family like a lot of money was like
three thousand dollars for me to go
there because i was i was getting sent
at every school but going to military
school
maybe if anything it taught me how to
like
if i was gonna do something
criminal or like something bad like it
was bad be a little smarter about it if
anything somebody there was like
criminal the whole military school was
just a bunch of terrible kids and they
were like really knew what they were
doing
um
so if anything i kind of like
it was like learning from the school of
hard knocks you know
but
i think being in military school even
that was only like for one year um and
my father he was a vietnam vet and
you know i think i can attribute his his
concept of discipline to it you know
like no matter how bad i was how much i
disagree with my father he gave me the
most
complex
rules of what discipline means
what it what it is to apply in whatever
you're doing and i didn't realize that
until i was older that you know these
what what makes my story successful what
makes me a better dj or what makes me a
better songwriter
it really
i don't have the technical abilities but
i have i always apply myself to find a
goal you know and i really feel like
that that's what my father gave me
before
before i turned into an adult because
it's just something i had inside me that
separated me from everybody else when i
got into the music business
work ethic was such a clear thread
throughout your story like relentless
almost at times it seems somewhat
obsessive work ethic and it's funny
because when i hear about your early
upbringing i guess my assumption is
because it sounds quite similar to mine
getting kicked out of school and and
being the only kid out of four siblings
that was like always getting bad grades
always in exclusion were people did
people around you think you were going
nowhere at that point yeah i mean even
until the mid-20s my father was like how
did you buy this house like how did you
what are you doing like there's no
there's no way
possibly you're making money with music
like it's like there's just no possible
way and i went to college i went for um
i went to ucf i got a little community
college because i couldn't afford like a
real school i did two years there just
basically just getting
just being in a school so i could have
something to advance forward and then
with the temple university in philly and
i ended up dropping out that school but
i went for anthropology and filmmaking
so it was like a really
two other degrees that would literally
turn into no job but i was obsessed with
documentary filmmaking i thought that
would be something i could i could do i
was obsessed with culture i was obsessed
with humans and people and the study of
culture and i was when i was a young
person i was reading national geographic
all the time and watching documentaries
so that was something i was like how do
i apply that you know
and my father's also like this is a huge
mistake what are you doing what about
accounting that's a great
degree to have
um in the end i think what i'd learned
at that university was
um because in the film program it was
like
there was a lot of creative avenues i
could learn from and the people who were
professors were almost like filmmakers
that didn't make it and they have to be
professors it kind of feels like so like
what am i doing here i want to learn
these people aren't even in the business
you know so the real business is like
going out and making it yourself and i
think i just did that set third year i
was like i'm out of school
but i kind of wish i had dropped out of
college earlier
and had a head start because it took you
a while when you're paying your college
tuition and working and it's so time
consuming and then eventually i started
to to to do music and do little odd jobs
like djing to where i was like oh i can
kind of like quit my jobs now and also
like yeah i think
if i knew now what i knew then i would
have done a different
journey but i think that's what makes
you who you are you know no matter how
long it takes and eventually you make
that decision to sort of start heading
towards music right um even though it's
not paying you at all and i was reading
about the jobs you were doing in that
period of your life you were worked at a
zoo at one point yeah you were a social
worker at one point yeah how long did
that period of your life when you'd made
the decision to move towards music and
that music was going to be your thing
how long was that it definitely wasn't i
mean i
at 22 years old i was already working
like nine to fives you know it was it
was like the social work job was my
first job as like this is a job that
feels good to do like you know i'm
working with children
i was going between teaching kids and
then after school program and just felt
like okay this is cool
um
it feels like i'm doing something for
somebody instead of working at like
subway and making money for the head of
subway which is kind of like a waste of
my energy but working with kids i felt a
little bit like
i i felt fulfilled you know
i think
but then you run into the bureaucracy of
of i was in a city like philadelphia so
it was just like so much corruption even
in like this the social work world it
was crazy
um
eventually i was getting beaten down at
that job too i was like this is this is
my life like 22 i'm like this is this is
all i can look forward to is like
building my way into like this job or
this job and
i think
i started
djing on the side uh at parties and
learning from the djs there because
philadelphia is a famous city for djing
it's like culturally one of the most
important cities in america um for
hip-hop for djing
and i just started doing parties and
then i saw
what you do if you do your own party
like you can invest invest in yourself
and promote a party and you take
everything right so i started learning
small little business acumen from just
doing parties
and then eventually i started i can quit
my job i can make it it was a huge step
because at that point you don't know
when you're doing
music and parties full-time
it's literally up to you to how much
you're working or what you're doing to
keep the money flowing to pay the rent
if i don't one month i'm not doing good
i don't care i can't pay rent i'm
homeless um it's not a consistent
paycheck music never is and it wasn't
for me for probably three four years but
yeah it took it just it's just literally
just putting your boots to the ground
and like doing the work and like failing
at it and learning what makes you better
what makes you more money like what's
how do you grow this business even in
these little small steps that's kind of
what i did in those
those first years my career and i wasn't
even really making my own music yet i
was just djing and making mixtapes and
making edits and learning how to use
computers still like i had nobody to
teach me i was buying
hardware or you know in high school
shoplifting from sam goody and sam ash
and like guitar center like samplers to
use so it really just came down to
just the grind to figure out what works
and what doesn't it was so evident even
when i was hearing about you like in the
record stores and ultimately selling a
record to can are they vinyls you were
selling to canadian samples and stuff
but throughout that even like you're the
story about you reading was it william
faulconer's book yeah and you're you had
this clear
hunger for learning
like teaching yourself how to make music
teaching yourself computers teaching
yourself the business side of things
most people don't have a predisposition
just to figure stuff out yeah and that
again when i'm trying to figure out
exactly how you became this global
superstar i'm like that feels to be a
consistent thread throughout your story
as well that learning hunger i think
when you think about what a dj is uh you
know now they're like david guetta
they're headlining festivals or even me
like i'm headlining my own shows but
back when i was growing up
you know
the big dj's from say detroit like uh
the magician or like you know after
bambada people that were djs
were like the selectors they were like
the guys who did all the work to know
what music is there what this music is
how this music exists and they were like
kind of the cultural benchmark they were
the guys who cataloged everything for to
distribute in the scene right um so i
think
i loved that like that was like i wanna
i love music like i love what it is i
loved and i went to parties and i
remember seeing people like quest love
and like cash money and these dj's like
carson baker playing crazy records like
playing fella cootie and then playing
like um
you know a disco record and then playing
something new like a local hip-hop
record and i was like and then they
playing like babe ruth like an old rock
and roll record i was i was so obsessed
with how they could connect these things
that don't make any sense musically and
that's what i always thought was the
great
i think story of what djs do is they're
like guys who can
process all this culture and give it to
you in a certain way and now it's more
streamlined like you're gonna go to
house party hear house music you're
gonna go to like a bastion party here
dance hall but the really special djs
were able to like do everything and so i
think
when i learned that was like a skill set
i started looking at vinyl i started
learning about different music i would
like ask djs what is that record be
playing who are these artists like what
is feather cootie where's
where's nigeria where do they make music
like what's it sound like you know then
i'm like we're the producers like oh uh
the guy from the who went to nigeria and
was a drummer there then he went back
and did this and then oh james brown
heard this guy and then he hired another
drummer this is like became like a web
of music i started to follow everything
and read lander notes and then i just
was obsessed with with gaining all the
knowledge about music whatever i could
and using that to apply to being a dj
that obsession just led me to being a
record collector you know like i said i
traveled a little bit at the end of my
university i went to india with one of
my professors to work on a documentary
and um
the border of pakistan in india is
called uh
in gujarat it was like this this little
uh kind of like a valley called the
round of kuch it was a huge earthquake
there i think around 2000 and i was
there doing some
sort of
building work and you know working with
uh red cross and things like that and
then i just kind of bounced and took a
motorcycle and just went all over india
and just explored my own and i bought a
bunch of vinyl at the time the most
expensive record in the world were these
beetle 78s they were like beetles
records but at
you find good ones in india they only
make money if you find good ones they're
worth like a thousand to a couple
thousand dollars but i was finding
indian soundtracks i was finding things
like
um there's a wreck a classic indian
soundtrack called chalamar with like
crazy like spy themes and like break
beats on it at the time if you find one
of those at a record shop pay like a you
know a couple rupees you could bring it
back to london and sell it at like
poland street for like you know 300
pounds so that was like this weird hack
i found like traveling and buying
records
i did it in india i did it in
philadelphia i would go to new jersey i
go to new york i would buy record old
records and sell it to different
record collectors you know nick quest
loves one of my first guys i sold to i
sold records to kanye west when he first
started producing um
collecting records was like a certain
business and on ebay that was another
hustle i had like selling things that i
buy flea market stuff and selling ebay a
lot of it was vinyl correct
one of the one of the thing to get
things again that's so um obvious and
apparent with you which is kind of a
thread that kind of weaves between many
of my guests specifically comedians for
some reason because comedians they at
some point you see this decision they've
made to like leave the city
leave like
their job in finance and pursue this
thing that has no apparent chance of
making them any money at all but they
just follow this like passionate
obsession they spend a year going up and
down the country working for nothing
because they're obsessed with comedy for
whatever reason and a lot of young
people when they think about being a dj
or an entrepreneur or whatever they
think to themselves okay i want the
admiration of standing there and all
these people clapping for me and the
money yeah but you were so clearly led
by this like unbelievably obsessive
passion which seems actually to be if i
was to say 95 of my guests um followed
one path it would definitely be they
didn't really care about the outcome
they cared about like the passion and
the pursuit of the passion yeah that's
so clear with you right i mean the
beginning was definitely a hustle like i
love music and it saved me from you know
when i even in high school i you know i
moved from different high school to high
school and i didn't have a friend group
so i kind of was like leaning towards i
want to play music but i couldn't my
parents wouldn't buy me a guitar like i
didn't even know how to play i was like
how am i going to learn a guitar you
know i'm going to learn piano
but i like was like djing that's like
the future of music like
my it was like turntablism was really
big i remember being in like 16 being
like i'm gonna buy record players that's
what i'm gonna buy that's like that's
what i'm gonna do as a as like a
creative person
this is like a futuristic way to do
things so
i i leaned into that started learning
what a dj was but in the beginning yeah
i had to do the groundwork to know what
it is i'm going to play like what it is
that the music comes from where was this
music at where do i buy the records what
do the crowds react to
etcetera etcetera so yeah
this formative years i spent time
grinding but then eventually i was like
okay how do i make money out of this and
yes i want to play for a crowd and they
saw my adoration yes i want to meet
girls of course
that happens later and that's another
drive but in the beginning i just i
didn't really expect to have a job out
of it you know
do you think you would have been
as successful as you are if you if
someone had taught you how to make music
and you'd been really mentored by
someone because sometimes that
hurts innovation and creativity if
there's a if convention is too involved
yeah you know what i mean i don't mean
because i see nowadays like kids can
literally learn and copy any style of
music in a day because they have a
tutorial it's so easy it's really easy
and i wish i had that but then at the
same time i wouldn't have i wouldn't
have had such a definitive like who i am
and if i were when people always ask me
when i do radio shows like what advice
you give to young djs and it's like
always the same thing like what makes
yourself unique like what what really
makes you different because i could
throw a [ __ ] rock and i'm going to
hit a dj or artist in the head in london
like there's somebody here it's like
i'm not talking about you
right but it's so easy like
i literally get demos all the time like
what i don't even care i don't even pay
attention i used to actually like try to
listen to demos i'm like this is all the
same [ __ ] like people are doing the same
thing over and over again like
you know whether whatever city you're in
there's like a thing and every once
while you get like a special person that
comes out of nowhere and you're like wow
that's unique like but really what what
is it like for me
you were talking about william faulkner
i really tapped into like my southern
heritage when i was younger i was like
what i loved like miami based music
growing up in florida i loved like um
you know the crunk scene the bouncing in
new orleans i grew up in tennessee for a
couple years so i loved like memphis rap
was like my favorite thing so when i
went to the east coast none of that
stuff was happening like nobody listened
to that music so i was like let me bring
this to the east coast let me start
playing at my parties and it took off
like all this new sounds i brought even
though they were just like a one-hour
flight down south to hear miami-based
music no one listened to it in philly so
i was playing the stuff
mixed with like 80s records and that was
like my brand i was the guy that was
like doing this mashup culture
and so nobody else had that party there
was like urban parties they'd be playing
hip-hop there would be you know rock and
roll parties playing like glam rock and
you could dance to it there would be
like
high-end parties playing house music but
nobody was playing for like the art
school kids and the hipsters the time
because it was pre-hipster it wasn't a
word yet and i was like that's my market
and i was like no one's tapped into this
let me go ahead and do this you know in
every style my every every little
venture i've done as a musician has been
like why is the one in this market like
even when i do major laser
it was like reggae and dancehall we were
doing but nobody was really doing it in
the clubs in america there was like if
you go to like philly you want to see
vibes cartel you you have to go to like
this one
ghetto club in like lancaster and it's
like only jamaicans there and i'm like
this is such crazy music like why don't
we do this on another level like why
don't we work with some of these artists
and do bigger records and so i was like
no one's doing dance hall let's do it
this project so everywhere i went i was
like
experimenting like what how do i do this
and kind of make it my own or how do i
like work this into my sets
and um it's been like a journey you know
this is 20 years now i'm doing this
since i played at my first show at
fabric
and it feels like
i've done so many
if you're a fan of mine and you follow
me for 20 years it's a really tough
journey because it's like i've done
you're gonna go to reggae music you're
gonna go to country music now you're
gonna go to deep house you're gonna go
this way that's way but a few people
actually go with me and follow my career
so um
you know i think that's what makes me a
one-of-a-kind person i guess so back to
my my point when young people give me
ask me questions of like what is it to
what kind of advice i can give you i'm
like what
find like a really unique thing and just
and just lean into that lean into that
so hard like figure out even if it feels
weird just make it make sense you know
make it make it work for you because
otherwise you're just going to be one
and one of a hundred like clones of
different djs different rappers if it
feels weird is that sometimes also an
indication that there's a big
opportunity there because it's it's yet
to break or it's yet to be discovered so
like weirdness might be a 100 yeah more
now than ever back then it was like i
mean even djs wasn't a thing when i
started doing it like you would you
wouldn't dj being a dj wasn't a career
it was like there's a few guys on the
radio
in europe is different there was a dj
culture here but in america there wasn't
like a job description called dj like
you wouldn't think there wasn't djs on
the radio weren't they weren't featuring
on their music
um
now it's pretty commonplace but
but
just being dj was unique for me but
nowadays
since there's so much
information all the time so much media
there's so much artists
fighting for
your eyeballs and your ears on tick tock
and instagram it's more than ever
important to have something like wow
i gotta go look at that again because
it's like just having a catchy hook's
not enough
everybody has a cat like there's a
thousand catchy hooks you can just go
and buy them literally at the market
it's like not special
one thing that really surprised me about
you as well is that you're
quite um
i don't know whether this is humble
about your talent but when i've seen in
multiple interviews when you're asked
what the biggest misconception is about
you one of them you said is that that
i'm talented
and i've heard you say a number of times
that you're faking it or that you're
still
looking for the some kind of like
validation that you're a real you know
and even at the start this conversation
you said i'm not technically the best or
yeah what is that is that impostor
syndrome what is that
no i think i've always been like more of
a conceptual artist like you know i
think of music and concepts i think of
music as like oh
it's like a math problem you know like
how does this add to this how do i make
it work you know it's always been like a
riddle every time i try to think of like
what to combine things
now it's a little easier because i'm
like i'm doing this kind of dance album
and i know exactly what works because
i'm using these records and i'm making
you know collaborations with friends of
mine artists but when i was younger i
literally my first album was called uh
florida it was on it was on ninja tune
and it's so weird like i remember being
just like so stoned and just [ __ ] up
and like making this record
and like
people still hit me back like that
record was a classic i'm like what are
you talking about it was like crazy
chaos it was like me just like in my
room in orlando like trying to figure
out how to i wasn't even things weren't
even in key like i'm sampling on this
like two channel little like a kai s20
sampler like that thing worked and
um
laying things out like if you know
anything about dws like workstations
like they're so complex like logic
ableton back then you used something
called cool edit pro and there wasn't
even like a piano roll or anything i
just had like windows like photoshop
when you just like i just layered
the loops on top of each other and
sequenced it in one long window because
i couldn't it was just it was the worst
way to work ever but i learned this
ass backwards way that kind of gave me a
little
flavor i guess
but i never was like a
a a musician you know like i never i
never mastered an instrument and i
always thought djing i never was a good
turntable it's like i mean if you put me
in my room with like a track or like dj
craze that's embarrassing those guys are
like
they're like magicians you know but
i thought
i'm the guy with like ideas and how do i
apply those ideas and it became easy
with as the technology advanced like i'm
like oh these programs make it a lot
easier for me i don't need to like play
my midi keyboard i don't need to be
scott storch you know i can just like
literally
see the audio ableton's my favorite sc
audio and i can work with raw audio it's
my mind works that way
so
i think
yeah i'm more of a conceptual person
than i am like a a like a
digital auteur even with even with
production i mean i always say like
skrillex is like the guy that blew my
mind like he uses like a computer like a
like a grand piano like he just does
it's the craziest thing he does you know
it's so i think there's people that are
in my generation that are like those
savants and i'm not that but i i kind of
mixed
my talent for new
new sounds and a talent for songwriting
to make
like who i am
but but to say that you're you're faking
it
and uh i mean maybe it was a joke but
yeah to describe it as
the biggest misconception i've been
talking about djing because i mean
literally it's probably like the most uh
it's people will ask me like how to you
know like how to do it or to do it it's
such a you can learn in 10 minutes like
how to do the technical sides you know
um
was i thinking that i mean no because at
the end of the day
what i think makes dj special that i
explained earlier is that you have this
hit you have to have history that's what
makes it special i think it's why you
have dj careers in in london especially
these guys are like david rodigan you
know he's like a guy who's like
in his like late 60s i'm hoping agent
maybe
but he's been doing this since he was
interviewing bob marley like he's a and
he still rocks parties playing like
selecting the perfect records because he
has
the skill set like he knows exactly he
can read a crowd in like southwest
london he can go to jamaica he can go to
like
italy you could play the right songs the
right time so
um there's something intrinsically
beautiful about you know being a dj but
yeah some things it feels like i'm
faking it but i mean even in the
beginning
i faked it to like
get get in the studio you know that's
what i did to like to to have my foot in
the door you know
quick one as the seasons have begun to
change so has my diet and um
right now i'm just going to be
completely honest with you i'm starting
to think a lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together we call
it fitness blockchain and i'm currently
at 81 percent
um so 81 of the days i've done a workout
in the last 150 days right so i'm going
to the gym about six times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivatio live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you for making
a product that i actually like the
salted caramel is my favorite i've got
the banana one here which is the one my
girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one when you are asked about your
creative process i i was looking through
the huge wealth of traveling that you've
done
brazil
india um spent time in london and
various parts of the world um how
formative is travel and going to these
different cultures and understanding the
way they do things to what the art you
ultimately created because when i think
about creativity from a marketing
standpoint i see it as like pulling
together lots of little pieces to form
something new and you you have because
of your obsession with the vinyls and
the musics and the samples you seem to
have this like huge wealth of like
artistic reference points yeah to create
new stuff from i'm just obsessed with
the conversation that's like happening
all over the world like you know whether
i go to brazil or are you london's a
good example where you have this like
pan-african jamaican caribbean and then
like
you know european thing happening that's
like drone based that's like funky
that's like
um now it's drill like there's all these
genres that if you look look into it why
it exists you can literally pinpoint the
first creators and like where they come
from and like why is it like
why do they make this kind of sound so i
was always like putting together the
equations like why are these things
happening and brazil's my favorite place
to to talk about because
i was hearing this music it was called
funk karaoke for a long time those girls
that were doing a party in philly and i
remember they gave me a mixtape and it
was this like sound that was a mix of
miami bass and samba and like heavy
metal because they're screaming songs
there's bass beats but they're using
like these tamborzino like drums
yeah so i was like what the [ __ ] is this
i like literally couldn't find any
information on this music
so i went to i went to i went to brazil
and i actually had a magazine fund this
trip it was it was an article for fader
magazine and i went down there i met the
big djs and i just became immersed in
that scene you know producing with some
of those guys learning to produce with
them
and um
[Music]
moving that sound forward a little bit i
think my first real real production was
with mia it was called bucky dungun and
it was a it was a funk record that we
did and remember we actually went back
to brazil and played it at this huge
festival it was like a massive hit in
brazil and actually helped i think maybe
validate some of the funk music in
brazil because before that it was like a
rio thing and it became like a
all over the country they were starting
and now if you go to brazil like funk
music is the most commercial thing back
then 20 years ago it was like a pretty
underground
genre and um
but yeah everywhere i go i'm like i want
to learn more once i learned like all
the catalog all the old producers from
you know jazz funk and soul and
hip hop then i'm like the rest of the
world is there's like endless
possibilities of where music comes from
and what's going on so i started like
venturing out there
in terms of your crazy process as well
you
in two different interviews i saw you
talk about creating music that lasts a
lifetime like really timeless pieces of
art and the question that i had when i
saw you say that was like how do you do
that how do you how can you even
anticipate that a music a piece of music
is going to be timeless is there
something in the design of it or the
inspiration or the story there's a
there's a few times in the studio and
i'm like a song i might be working on
gives me goosebumps you know that that
happens um
it was like when i did the we did justin
bieber's wear you now like something
like that like just was like well what
the hell are we doing
and then like lean on from major laser
that was a record that i've probably
spent
one year on the production you know
because i did so many different videos
like no this isn't right now this isn't
what's happening right now this is i
need to do something as a producer my
job is to predict the future like when i
release this record after i make it it's
going to take like three months to
actually get
to the people you know because it's like
you need to go with labels clearing the
record it can't just be like back then
they would make a edit and dj it and it
was like hitting people right up but my
little local neighborhood but a
producer's job is literally like try to
like at least mine my forte's always
been like
how can i do something that's going to
be big in like six months or like a year
like kind of like being futuristic
sounding because that's what the big
that's what the greats have always done
you know prince or timberland or
pharrell they've always made records
that trendset because they were so
futuristic so my goal has always been to
follow them never to follow a trend um
and those two records were ones that we
did and we're like yes this is going to
work even though it's [ __ ] crazy or
even palm the floor i remember listening
that and driving around in the car um
that was the song i did for major laser
and we're driving around la and looking
at the guy who produced me named switch
and we were just like
this is is this gonna work it was so
crazy like we were just like this is so
wild and then
and then yeah like four years later
beyonce sampled that record and it
became a massive hit so there was like
my career has always had these little
moments where we do things and then they
the ramifications happen later you know
you feel the effects you know the seeds
like you said
um
but yeah having classics is important i
think a couple times you know when
you're on you're in it and you're like
okay this is this is worth the time this
is worth the effort because
learning songwriting with some of the
great guys like um
you know dr luke saw my publishing in
the beginning and having been in the
studio with him and circuit and a lot of
his writers i was like man you've spent
three days on like a second verse like
this is what you do now
that's what pop music is like you
literally like if you think a record is
the big record
you it's it's so painstakingly like like
the effort is so concise like how to
make this the best record ever like
everything is like a
perfect addition like an architect like
every little corner of the house has got
to be perfect right so i learned that
process which i don't do very often but
when a record is big i follow through
and otherwise
just do a [ __ ] ton of records one of
them is going to be good too that's
another process you can do which also i
can do that too like just put you know
randomly i put records out and record
like on my mind
which is another house records on my
album that was a huge tick tock record
which
would never you would never guess like
you can't even guess when those records
happen
yeah so because you can't guess when
one's going to be a winner and maybe
one's not going to catch on
as a creative do you kind of try and
not
harm your piece by trying to predict too
much what the outcome's going to be do
you just focus on the process itself and
like how much can you can you predict if
something's going to be a i mean there's
a lot of like in this like we're talking
about being in the studio so like i said
there's a process like to making a great
record but there's also like diplomacy
when you're in this when you're a
producer like you have to know the
artists like you know
ed sheeran you have an extra record we
can try to work on and then he gives you
songwriting and that's how like a record
like cold water happened was another uh
bieber song i did
and then you're like okay how do can we
ask bieber's manager can he maybe do
this record we'll do a trade for
production okay then that deals in the
place then okay who can play the guitar
on this oh you find that person so
sometimes it's literally like
being like a an ambassador like talking
all these people try to put a record
together too like that's another process
that i had to learn and that's something
else like when a record's already done
like you take a song and you dress up
the production you still have to
find the like all the keys to make that
record work
um
so it's like
every record is a different journey you
know and now with dance music i'm
literally just in the studio
hearing records and trying to figure out
what sound i want to make for a live
effect and then i apply that in the
studio
but um i've literally probably every
kind of songwriting you can do i've i've
done it you know from like sitting with
acoustic guitar with madonna to
you know recording sound field
recordings in a favela or uh
you know
paying for a studio session for a
regular artist with like my last little
bit of money in philly like it's at uh
at um
you know the root studio and like barely
getting a hook and then it was not even
good enough to making something out of
that later you know like it's always
like it could be collections of vocals
or sample packs everything i've done you
know i've tried it you know what's the
cost of all of this in terms of on your
maybe cost is a bit of a presumption but
what's the the sacrifice or the cost in
terms of like personal life balance
because i think you're obsessed you're
obsessed with no i think i i wasn't i
was probably running at like 200 miles
an hour until cove it happened i don't
think i would ever take a break and that
was probably the best thing that
happened like when i got one coveted
when the lockdown happened and i
couldn't do shows like [ __ ] let me
actually buy a house and let me actually
like you know like
figure out what's my next steps in life
i kind of needed that break so i was
just going to do everything was
breakneck speed you know it was like the
grammys this weekend oh you have a
session with this person speaking about
we gotta get back on this i gotta go to
jamaica and do this it's like everything
was happening i never said no to anybody
i was like this is crazy i was like
you know a musician has the same life as
i have as an athlete you have like a
peak you know
if you're a linebacker in nfl football
your career is like maybe three or four
years because you're getting beat up a
quarterback can play for you know
tilly's 44. um
a producer or artist like they're just
hot for as long as they're hot and then
they
have to find that they have to come down
some of them can just continue to always
go there like you know you have like
people that are just always going to be
in your mind like madonna or
you know um
some of the big pop stars like taylor
swift every record is going to perform
but a lot of times you like on borrow
time you don't know when you're when
you're when your window's going to close
so for me i was like i got to keep going
keep going and i never i feel like i
never had hit my my peaks i was like
let's keep pushing it forward and
eventually i was like you know what this
isn't that important like let me like
actually enjoy my life i have three kids
now
i want to like do things i want to want
to you know explore more but not think
about the work i want to do things that
maybe benefit
my my mind and i think that's kind of
what
the the last two years of downtime has
given me even though i did produce a lot
of records in between it was on my own
terms you know i wasn't like chasing all
the live events and i wasn't chasing all
the different uh successes i could have
had um covered was very much the same
experience for me it's actually why i
resigned from my company because i i
actually got to look at my life it was
like when when i stopped flying
eight times a month um i got to look at
my life and um i also got to feel what
it was like to slow down and talk to my
friends my family a little bit when you
think about your pre-covered life um now
you've got the hind the benefit of
hindsight and you've had time to pause
um
were you happy in that phase of your
life
i was because
it's weird i mean
i was losing touch with thing other
people i felt that so i was like very
insular but my life
i run the best like when it's chaos when
i'm doing 300 shows a year and i'm like
getting up and doing the emails and
going to the gym and then i'm like this
is like i just i just work under
pressure i don't know what it is it's
like my my like my best forte is is to
have
just chaotic stuff happening all the
time and i'm like somehow i can get
through it so i was into that and i was
like this is a very unhealthy way to
live
um
so now it feels like i'm back on a promo
tour and it feels like i'm back on this
like fast track a fast track and i'm
like i
kind of want cove a little bit but then
you know it's all part of the process
because you put a record out it's
important for people to hear it you know
you only have one chance for records to
be released and it's like you should
give that if you have a great song you
should give it every opportunity it has
to reach people because that's it's it's
one shot you know
um but don't waste your time on every
song like you have a good song i got
this one the song miguel that we're
promoting i'm like this song's worth the
work you know other songs may be like
i'll put them out and maybe something
will happen you don't never know maybe
it's in three months
there'll be like a [ __ ] dancing to it
on tick tock or something and like it'll
be it's a crazy experience or something
and it goes viral you never know what's
gonna happen it's like just rolling the
dice every time but every once while
there are some steps you can take to
ensure a record has its best chance at
surviving you know
and that's like what you're doing now
right like the promo yeah putting effort
behind it um just so then so so covert
happens your world kind of grinds to how
everybody's does and you probably find
yourself in a house somewhere
alone yeah how's that then in terms of
mental health and dealing with the
sudden stop i i think
uh i mean the the thing that sucked the
worst about code is to have
these children and like it was a time i
was like man i can do whatever i want
but there's nothing to do
like you couldn't go to l.a we closed
the parks for so long because there was
no school like you know there's no
birthday parties you can't go see other
kids like it was just kind of like it's
almost like a a waste opportunity i had
like a whole year to do my kids i was
like what do we even find time to do
it's like i buy a house with basketball
courts in the house just play basketball
like it was like literally i made an
environment for them to enjoy life
but um i think
honestly i've been doing this for so
long and i've made a really great team
around me like i have these great women
that like are like that always work with
me and like work for me and i think
it just feels like it's a big family
like now you know like people like it's
a team whether it's like on my
management side or just like my personal
side it's like i have people that are
always looking in my best interests and
i think
i got lucky i was i've been doing that
since day one like my first manager
worked for me for free for the first
year because he just like believed in
what i did i was like i don't need a
manager i was making so much money
before i pay taxes like just selling
mixtapes and djing like i was like
i bought i bought a property in
philadelphia like in my first year of
like learning how to hustle the system
of being a dj and then i was like damn
but there's he was like there's there's
more to be done though like he's like
there's more you can do than just living
in philly and like buying being the
biggest dj here and i think he gave me
that that motivation to like be bigger
and from him you know another management
group happened and then i've had a lucky
journey i've been the same with the same
team for you know 20 years
a lot of people don't get that i also
think i was very visionary in what i
want to do so if you're like a young
person like you get sucked up by
management or whatever they might have a
vision for you or they might not or they
might not have the right vision for you
or they might not give you the room to
be yourself
then you're going to switch like 40
managers and you might not ever find you
know the success you need so it's
important to find people
you know
that really believe in you but also let
you be yourself because you got to find
that because you're going to be that's
all you got at the end of the day you
can lose a million managers and a
million people but you can always start
over and just be you reminded me of the
avicii documentary that i saw which was
a real pivotal moment in my life because
um
yeah so i spent four weeks at home in
2019 and i was very much being dragged
around we had a thousand employees so i
was being dragged around the place and
that documentary taught me the
importance of saying no to stuff 100
like i beat you i feel like i never his
he was probably like one of my biggest
influences even though it's younger than
me i remember hanging out with a couple
times i was just like man this guy
this guy's a genius but like he doesn't
feel like he's he's in his own skin you
know because i don't think he ever had
that chance to be who he be
be what he wanted to be he was like
he was almost like a became like a
machine because his success happened so
quick
um but that happens a lot that's like
the one story to the dj world but in the
pop world
happens like way too much i think
are you good at saying your stuff no i
say yes everything but i'm also like i
have really thick skin i feel like my
personality is enormous i can also like
i can i can find my way through things i
always say yes and then i'll say no for
the next time if it sucks but yeah i've
done everything you know and i'm like uh
you know
this isn't the right thing i move on or
even if it's a studio session i might go
get breakfast and i might never come
back you know whatever it is i'll give
everything a chance you know but uh
i know
i know now
some things you know my management knows
me now to where they something don't
even get to me the questions aren't even
going to come because they know it's
like a no or they know i'll say yes it
was a bad it'll be a bad yes
thick skin yeah you started talking a
lot about mental health over the last
couple years your partnership with calm
as well i was reading about um
mental health in the djing world but
mental health amongst men anyway what's
your journey been with your own mental
health
i think you know just being put as like
a
you know whatever
celebrity or whatever it is
being attention always on you
is you're gonna have so many critics and
you're gonna have so many you know the
love is cool but nobody really cares
about like all the adoration you get you
care about the people that don't like
you and that you get caught up in that
even if it's only like
five percent but they really want to be
vocal about they don't like you or they
don't love you uh that bothers you no
matter who who you are you know
eventually i had to just like wow these
people suck like just whatever you're
gonna it's you're never gonna get away
from those
the people that like
want to always be critics you know they
just want to get a rise out of you i
think
eventually you just got to say
[ __ ] it the people that around me their
opinions what matters like the people
that i trust and you can't like kind of
sit in the opinion of people that don't
either don't know you or
maybe build an opinion about you from
you know whatever it is because when it
comes to social media
it's like a game you know it's not like
you it's it's look i was talking about
conor mcgregor earlier today i'm like
he's like the biggest heel his most paid
athlete last year even though he didn't
fight because he's like people love to
hate him you know so he built a brand
out of just being that person um
but you got to take it with you got to
take the good and the bad with it i mean
if you if you want to be in this
business which is like i guess show
business like you said the comedians the
dj's i'm like kind of like a popular dj
i'm more like a like a people i go to my
shows and i even know my music because
they know my brand and that kind of
sucks because you don't you don't know
if they don't know who they're gonna get
but um because i'm on that pedestal
you're just gonna get
eyes on you for everything so i feel
like
you just have to if you want if you want
the success if you want to be at this
level you got to like just take it and
if i didn't want it i would just back up
you know but i can take it so i feel
like it's something i had to learn to
grow into myself and just be like okay
be comfortable because what really
matters is my team you know who my
family thinks about me what my
team thinks about me and i think that's
those people give you that motivation to
go every day have you made a conscious
effort to like shorten
that
circle by like logging off i read
somewhere that someone else has your
twitter password now and you don't
really have it and have you made a
conscious sense yeah i've been on
twitter in like five years but i think
um yeah it kind of sucks i hit or miss
because i mean even tic talk i was like
slow to do that but then like i said if
you want your if you want your
your brand to exist it's got to be there
like because that's like you know
there's more eyeballs on tick tock than
they're on youtube nowadays so you
really
you have to be part of that conversation
with the audience um
it took me a while like how to find
people that actually could help me run
that because i couldn't do it myself and
i couldn't be
you know in every day long like
videotaping and doing dances or whatever
so how to find different ways to make
those things work for myself um it
wasn't easy in the beginning
but uh yeah i don't stay on i don't stay
on social too much but then of course
during this album cycle i'm on there and
i'm like
having to always participate but
you know luckily
i think i've got great fans i've got
great people get great response to my
album it wasn't that difficult but
every once in a while you have to get
you take your mind off it because you
can get caught up you know
well what made you start talking about
mental health and
being a bit of an advocate for that you
said that a lot of people should speak
about it a lot more why did that
inspiration probably after the avicii
situation and then you know i work with
a lot of rappers i think i had i had a
hip-hop album that came out like two
years ago three years ago maybe four
years ago it's called california and i
had a little zan and i had a little peep
on it and i had um trippy red and i had
i was working with xxxtentation i just
remember
i did this whole circuit working all
these young rappers they were like
really young they were like 19 20 and
the studio sessions were so weird and
crazy and then
start these these rappers all started to
die like they all started like you know
little peep overdosed on um opiates and
you know x was was shot
but he also had such a crazy
vision on life and experiences and his
he was like went through so much and i
saw i saw what was happening to these
young guys
because they were getting so
popular so quick and i was really
i just i just like damn
these guys all need like a big brother
so i think just with those guys a lot of
them i was helping them out making
decisions but
just seeing how crazy it is to be a 20
year old right now is is much more
difficult than when i was there you know
when i was there you literally had
your group of friends and that's all you
knew the people on your street now
everybody knows who you are or can know
you who you are or have have some kind
of opinion about you and
i think you have to find ways to
like i said earlier block that out and
just concentrate on like being the best
you which sounds like a cliche but
you really have to compete with just
yourself every day not everybody else
one of the things i saw in that vichy
doc as well was he was suffering with
pretty severe anxiety i remember the
scenes of him being in that hotel room
and his manager saying we've got to go
and him saying i i'm not going yeah have
you ever felt that anxiety have you ever
felt that that kind of crippling
no i think you know
i've i deal like people like close my
life have anxiety and they have a tax
law and i have to
talk them down sometimes um so i know
how how it feels and that's just like in
the day-to-day life
me i feel like i still like the stage
i've never been and i've also like i
said i've also made a a a concerted
effort to make the team like make me
comfortable you know that much
documentary i'm not going to talk about
like the people on team but like they
just like
they just didn't care like no one cared
about him or what he was feeling i
remember being at shows i was like he
played before in vegas and he would be
just missing he would play like two
hours later
and he would have to get [ __ ] up to
get on stage because he just couldn't do
it he couldn't be up there it couldn't
be on a pedestal and i feel like i could
feel that way sometimes like on this
tour you know just jet lag alone you're
like
like nodding out at dinner and you're
like i gotta go be excited for this
crowd
and um
i'm really good at like
making that work for myself now so these
people oh you know
i owe them this experience but yes
i take a lot more time for myself now
like i'm like i don't this i don't need
to do these anymore i'm telling them
like this is this is over for me this is
like something i would do three years
ago it's important to to take that
that away that will out of the equation
i'll feel a lot better but yeah you got
to make those personal choices and you
got to
like i said people that are that are
hungry like me and you that just that
when they get on the train they're just
like going full throttle you do need
something to say like okay it's it's
okay to like not go 100 miles an hour
all the time you can like go like at a
strolling pace or something and i guess
for you from what i read a lot of that
was your kids as well right yeah when
you when when your first child was born
you talked about that being a really
pivotal moment it taught you that type
the value of time and i think my first
kid when i had my first son lock it i
just
i was like i went i actually went faster
so i was like i did i was like also as a
father
your kids i was like
did i found a connection with my sons
when i was they were like five and four
years old when they were like because
really the mother's like everything
they're not leaving her sight they're
not around they're not they don't really
give a [ __ ] about like their fathers i
felt like that in the beginning of my
son but so i was like i got a kid now my
life's about to get really complicated
and i i think all my my best work
happened around them because you said
time management was like okay
i have like saturday sunday or have like
wednesday off i'm gonna go to the studio
for 16 hours every other day because i
don't want to do anything else this is
the time i have like those five years i
did all of my biggest records
and my next time was born and my time
got even crazier
and then um
[Music]
he just kind of like like i said you got
to manage time better each time like you
gotta
gotta figure out how to make it work
i'm still figuring it out you know now
my boys are entering like the teenagers
like they're 11
7.
so they're asking me questions now that
they never would before like i'm like
having to give them like
you know boy man advice which i was like
this is cool they're having
conversations that
i can relate to them as much as they can
relate to me before it was like we just
baby shark and
legos and stuff
when you um talking about
your three boys when you you did this
really sweet post um giving a bit of a
shout out to their mothers and in that
sentence you said i'm still a work in
progress and i was really intrigued by
that why did you say i'm still a work in
progress as it relates to a post about
the mothers and your boys i think
because you know my my boys i want them
to to i want them
like i want to instill in the same
discipline that my father has given me
you know which i don't know how to do
that like i don't think my father knew
either like he had i remember going to
my father's rooms and he would have like
books about like
being the best dad you know like i
remember like i was like well i was like
and i think that about till i was later
i'm like damn
maybe i should check that book out you
know like i'm like i was seeing silly
when i was younger
but i think being the person i am i'm
also like this like like i said my
personality is so big that i feel like
i'm kind of alpha even for my children
like i'm like when i when i'm off break
i'm like let's go snowboarding let's go
to the basketball court and they're just
like dad
relax like we want to watch tv or
something you know i'm like and i'm like
why don't they want to do all this stuff
with me like i'm like they think i'm
like the crazy person that comes over
and like takes them away to do crazy
stuff all the time and it's like
it's a big distraction in their life a
lot of times so i've got to figure out
how to like
be with them you know more than just be
there
in saying sports dad i gotta like be
their their their friend too
so that's like what i'm talking about
things like that when you
you know just even like sitting with my
son
my seven-year-old and like watching
cartoons or watching him play minecraft
on his ipad is so much more important
than him if i do that for an hour then
like take him on like a trip to nepal or
something which i've done you know like
it's like they're like they remember
that but they actually remember this
time and on the couch with me a lot more
i feel like
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewelry brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of jewelry
and this piece by crafted when i put it
on for me it represents courage it
represents ambition it represents being
calm and loving and respectful and
nurturing while also being the
antithesis of that seemingly the
antithesis of that which is
sometimes a little bit aggressive with
my goals and determined and courageous
and brave the really wonderful thing
about crafty jewelry is it's super
affordable it looks amazing the pieces
hold tremendous meaning and they are
really well made the other thing that we
were talking about just then is this um
just came to mind is when i had
olympians on this podcast they talked to
me about this thing called gold medal
depression and israelita sanjay came
here the ufc champion um two weeks ago
and he said that the worst day of his
life was the day after he won the belt
yeah he said he went straight into
therapy and i i saw a similar tone and a
similar narrative and when you spoke
about
in fact some of the worst days are
the day after the high yeah
and then you you actually said that you
have to kind of suppress the high 100 to
avoid the low yeah always
so i feel like it gets addicting
because i mean like israel healing he
has like what like two big fights a year
like i'm like doing like which is i'm
not knocking him because these are
[ __ ] amazing but
um i have to do like 250 like shows you
know like sometimes and every night
might be bigger some nights might be
lame
you got to just take it straight every
once i'm like damn that was awesome and
i'm like appreciate the like
you have to have gratitude for that but
i mean if it's going to be your
lifestyle
every night people are always like you
don't drink when you're dj i'm like i'm
djing like 200 nights a year i can't be
drunk
i'll be dead like it's like it's like i
don't know it's like not even why even
asking that question it's like this is
still a job for me i found ways to like
have energy and like have this feeling
and like it's like it's actually i think
it's mental work to do that
but you always
if you're just going to be like in these
peaks and valleys all the time that's
not healthy and i see a lot of people
that are other creators and
it's crazy but like the best creators
are really like have bipolar tendencies
i've noticed that like some of my my
favorite people i collaborate with i've
noticed they have
and some of them aren't addressing it
and it's like it leads to
their six their failures in some parts i
always see like i think my
the most creative people like have are
always dealing with that you know either
whether it was bowie or uh other djs
like i see that a lot and my peers
and
i think it's important to
because they love that high too they're
chasing that hive like that experience
you know
it's just like a drug like having like
fans you know scream being at a festival
but
eventually you just kind of like drown
out the noise and just figure out
just
make it more of a job
because you can't just live like
every night's like the biggest party of
your life you know because then it will
be there's going to be a big downer and
you've changed yourself you said you
trained yourself to be like present and
energetic without letting the adrenaline
fill your body and then staying up till
7am oh so yeah it's so hard it's hard to
sleep you know like when you do a show
like i'm leaving vegas i'm doing like
the great party we like do one to three
a.m and i'm like have a little vibe
after the show and then it's like damn i
gotta go back so i gotta be up at nine
to take my kids i'm like
how do you like wind down because that's
really hard to do too i had the tiniest
dose of this we took this podcast we
made it a musical and we did three
nights at the palladium
and then
so i i started going to sleep at 7 00 am
so i'd come off stage at the play maybe
midnight come back here and i'd sit here
at the table just like it's impossible
that's why i'm touching this coffee yeah
i'm
so you have to literally
i think you have to take in strides
you know because it's always going to be
i think
i think deep down inside of me if i like
lose
all of the if i label drop me i couldn't
make music anymore i'm not djing i don't
really you know like i've i flopped so
hard
i feel like i can start over again
that's like something i feel inside me
okay maybe i would be like i love
furniture maybe i'll be a carpenter
whatever it is that's the thing i'm
saying i just feel like i feel like or
pizza maker whatever it is i always feel
like if you have that feeling inside you
that you can lose everything and be okay
with it that's
maybe that's the key to success then you
know it's all this is just like a facade
like it's really like i'll be
comfortable as long as i get to do
something i love again it doesn't have
to be huge don't be rich but i feel like
any moment if i got taken away i have my
family i have my kids and i'm
i'll gladly go and do something
with them and
live a humble life i always feel like
i'm that's some i'm ready for that you
know and your new album this is what 20
years into your career now and it's your
second full-length yeah album since like
florida yeah that's that's happened
because
uh
once i started going to this studio in
l.a i was like this you don't make solo
albums like florida you make albums for
other people
you know i'm just a dj i'm like a brand
this brand is limited to some a level
but if i work on britney spears album
well i can make this much money or i can
make a hit that streams like this or if
i do this album and it wasn't until i
think we did a major laser i was like
okay well at least i can own this
project also and make the same
size records
and take all of it you know that became
kind of like just
the business side of it i was like this
is
a lot
better you know now and this i think
finally dipped those to the point where
like okay i have no other brands to put
it in this is going to be my records now
kind of like that's kind of how this
album happened because that's still it's
a dance album but i worked on it
as a songwriter you know because you
hear the songs
they got verse chorus verse they're not
straight techno records they're not
straight
acid records they're just like they're
kind of built like pop records
20 years in um
releasing this album what are you sick
of
in the process in the industry what are
you just like i hate this [ __ ] uh i
think going through heathrows like
the liquids come on like what is up with
that
if i could not travel ever again that
was i mean i literally had to spend like
30 minutes there yesterday because like
i was like they were looking for this
one
tiny eye cream that was in the bottom of
a freaking i was like bro you can have
all this stuff just take it take it away
from you
but the travel is the worst you know i
wish i could teleport to each show but
uh it's that's probably the worst thing
if i could just not if i could just
sit home
i also got a really nice house now in
malibu so i'm like don't want to go on
tour anymore i kind of want to sit there
i love i love the when i was on twitch i
was djing
it's cool i've been in europe in three
years so it's
you know it's actually feels brand new
to me
in this in this line of work
the whole audience changes like every
three years too
like kids that were ravers they go to
clubs when they're 24 when they're 27
they got full-time jobs and their little
cousins have been i've done like
it's 20. i've done like seven of those
generations i feel like and they're
still coming out and seeing me play so
i've been really lucky based on the life
you've lived when your three boys get to
you know 16 18 years old and they come
to you and say
dad i need advice on like what i should
pursue how do i become successful what
is the general advice is there anything
that stands out to you or is it just
man i will take them on the road with me
i guess that's the only thing i can do
it's the best that's the best advice i
can give them like this is what i do
every day just so you know you think i'm
like
doing some crazy [ __ ] i actually have to
wake up and go to the gym they have to
go we're doing some press and promo they
have to get ready for the show we're
gonna do dinner with a promoter as a
nice favor and we're gonna go to the
concert oh there's appearance afterwards
this is what i do and i go back in the
morning i'm going to studio first thing
in the morning just to show them what a
tight what it takes like and this is
like you know 10 years in just let them
know it's
what the process is like that's the best
i can do i can actually show them that
you know a lot of kids wouldn't have
that wouldn't have their parents to give
them something like that
um
but yeah that's what i trained with
george foreman junior he's a he's a
boxing
trainer and his father he said that he
didn't really understand anything about
life till his father took him to the on
the road to see him fight and took him
to like the gym sessions and how much
work he did and i was in the middle of
like george's like uh the griddle he was
doing the former grill era
and um he said it just like
something clicked inside of him they
changed him inside why the gym you've
mentioned that twice is that because oh
because i think i just i actually every
day i have to go to the gym it's like
the one thing that i have to do to like
make me feel
like normal
because i
the jet lag for one but then i also
traveling and then i think i need like
an hour if it's yoga after something i
just need like to sweat for an hour
every day to feel normal i don't know
what it is but it's been like that for
like the last
10 years
it's not a very healthy lifestyle i mean
i don't drink very often but this kovid
got me into drinking again because it
was a little bit boring to go
to eat dinner every night so i think i'm
i'm trying to reset that a little bit
when someone's obsessive and they
achieve success and they're flying 300
but they have 300 shows a year i can't
it's an inconceivable number in my mind
um
their relationships in terms of their
romantic relationships like how on earth
does one maintain good romantic
relationships when they're that obsessed
i've had i've been
it's it's it's been hard
i had a girlfriend during the covert
times and she was like
great energy she understood my life
really does understand your lifestyle
because it's it's so fast-paced also
you're going to be
it's about you it's like you're the
artist right it's like and when i was
dating people that were in the music
industry
in the beginning i didn't understand at
all like
that they're two different people one's
the person that i know and then one's
the artist you know because that's a
whole facade i go on the stream on stage
you go see them do this it's not the
person that you see in the bedroom at
the end of the night or whatever it's
different i couldn't figure out i
couldn't figure that out as a young
person like
and that's why i don't think it's
probably not that healthy to date
someone else that's also in the music
business because it's like really
it's like smoking mirrors a lot between
what they're doing what they what their
what their shows are like
and who they are as a person and who
they are as a as like an artist is
different do you value that do you value
romantic connection is it a big i do
priority yeah i do i have i think
you know i have two uh
mothers of my children and like finding
the balance with them has been like the
hardest thing but it's like so great now
it's like so peaceful like they
everybody's in like everybody loves each
other and like my kids are all happy and
the mothers are happy and um everybody's
healthy that was been the and then you
know if i have a new girlfriend i
brought her into the mix and they liked
her too it was like so i've like found
this kind of
harmony in it you know but um there's
always turbulence you know having having
a fight now like with school my son goes
to high school so i have to like
navigate that problem there's like new
problems all the time you know never
you're never going to figure everything
out are you difficult to be in a
relationship with
i think no because i'm literally like
i'm down i'm just whatever i'm along for
the ride i'm like whatever but then of
course i have these kind of scorpio
tendencies i have like zero emotions so
like it's hard to really is there any
zero emotion yeah there's like nothing
you're gonna get nothing from me most
time i feel like yeah so a lot of girls
they but if you spend enough time with
me you know the real me but i think it's
it takes a while you're going to get
nothing from me most of the time in
terms of emotions yeah i'm really
emotionless emotionlessness i feel like
i don't i don't show a lot of
emotion you know i'm kind of like
i can make this workout for my dad i'm
just like
like an army guy you know i'm like out
here just like saving fate like poker
face i'm always like
it's hard to get
through my exterior
um is that a good thing do you think for
like in terms of mental health it's just
yeah i mean i found people that could
deal with it you know probably not a
good thing no
but it's been like that i think that's
also the thing you have to put on to be
like i said be in this world too like to
like
it's definitely uh something to protect
me but
at the same time
you know if you get the right person
you you give her everything
i sat here with patrice evra he's the
you're a football fan you're an arsenal
fan right so patrice evra was the the
famous manchester united left back and
he said something similar to me he said
he grew up on the streets of france drug
dealing he watched his brothers in his
house die from drug overdoses in the in
the bathroom and then his head teacher
at the time like sexually molested him
so he put up this and to survive on the
streets of france at the time he put up
this big kind of external outer wall
tough skin as you might have called it
and that served him to becoming an elite
athlete he served him to a point and
then one day his girl turned to him on
the sofa and said are you happy and he
was like fight back yeah i'm happy yeah
but then she kept persisting right like
angrily right that that defense and then
she kept persisting and he just broke
down and he'd never told anybody what
happened to him with his headmaster and
he told her at like 35 years old and he
said to me while he was sat here that
journey of like opening up and not being
the tough guy anymore actually changed
his life it changed his relationship
with his kids it meant that he finally
talked about how he felt for the first
time even though it made him feel
vulnerable and that's why i asked the
question is it is it a good thing like
to be you know i'm i think i'm i'm very
selfish because at the end of the day
i'm never lonely on the road and i think
it's because
i've never fell in love with a girl like
i never felt like ah this is love
because if really if it was love it's
love like the love is like love like you
i mean i had my heart broken maybe i was
in love a little bit but
like i never felt like life changing
love until my son was born and i was
like that the love i have with my my
firstborn son and then my second my
third is like the connection though i'm
like damn no matter what this kid stuck
with me like this is like my life
partner for real like this is like
somebody that i have to make this person
a better human like that was something
that when that happened it became
like my go-to like i'm always gonna this
is the this is the person that i care
the most about all three of these boys
it really
that was the first time i understood
love was when i had children you know
maybe that sounds weird to you but just
feels like that's undeniable like no
matter what they do i'm gonna love them
like you know do you believe in love
romantically
maybe not maybe i don't i don't have it
i mean
i'm still like playing the game like i'm
still you know
like you know trying to find a great
woman to settle down with our previous
guests always write a question for the
next guest and then funnily enough i
never tell the guest who the previous
person was he wrote a question for you
didn't know who he was writing it for he
he wrote um
why do you exist
maybe it is to
joy and inspiration to people and maybe
have you know in some
in
maybe
new music and exploration into culture
i hope and then in like a more spiritual
way
it is to
just add something to the world that
wasn't there before because everything
you create in the fabric of time and
space is something that's brand new and
that's what we that's only what we add
so the three answers amen thank you so
much and thank you for for coming here
your new album diplo which me my
girlfriend sat on this table a couple of
days ago listening to it's remarkable
that someone 20 years into their career
can create a project that feels so fresh
and relevant and exciting at the same
time i honestly i i played the record
for my girlfriend we're going through
the records you guys do it podcast no no
we we we
did it here and i was like oh i was like
diplo's coming in and so i started
playing the new records in the album and
she's from france in portugal she lives
in indonesia i know that one she says i
know that one oh because a lot of this
is a razor yeah well yeah and it was and
i i literally had to check the year in
which the album had dropped because they
the the songs felt so
familiar yeah and and that really took
me off guard but um i'll be honest we
added a couple tracks already out yeah
yeah yeah yeah from the view numbers i
think the streams go up first week a
little bit but uh yeah but um
there's there's they're part of the
project i mean i had i got really lucky
here in the uk i had the song with paul
wolford called looking for me that was
like so big here i was so it was like my
probably my biggest solo record
i've ever had in anywhere was that was
like number one ireland it was number
two here but um i feel like the uk
really
if anything the dance culture they
understand it like they get it it's been
a while you guys have like real dance
projects like
you know chemical brothers chase of
status bicep uh disclosure you have like
the idea of like dance projects which we
don't have in america we just have like
a bunch of like
scummy djs going out every night and
playing in las vegas but we're trying to
build it i think it's important but here
you guys have this culture it's amazing
well thank you for blessing us with
another project and it's legendary that
it's so resonant 20 years into your
career yeah so it's really really
inspiring thank you for being here thank
you huge pleasure thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you